i would divide science fiction up
temporally
there's um
far future science fiction which we
would call space opera people are
zipping around the galaxy star wars
chart star trek space opera people know
what it is but it's a form of fantasy as
i tried to show in my novel aurora but
it's a great story space there's no no
knock against space opera it's not
normally what i do in fact i think i've
only tried it once or twice
but it's out there and a lot of people
when you say science fiction they're
thinking just that but there's also near
future science fiction and it's very
common in science fiction that the
present is is presented
as a few years
pushed down the line with some classic
sf extrapolation of trends to show what
seems interesting and now it's a form of
realism to write now and reads as such
it's better realism than literary
fiction is with without a doubt
and that's a a big part of why science
fiction has an impact in the world
then there's the middle zone
relatively deep populate
um what i call it future history a
century out two centuries out three
centuries out
if you think about it you're not going
to find too many science fiction
classics that fit that song but if you
think about my career the mars trilogy
new york 2140 that's the year
2312 that's the year
where you actually see not just what
will happen with the present pushed but
what kind of historical change is
possible from where we are right now and
you can say well yeah i mean it could
happen no laws of physics are broken
it's not space opera there's a history
that runs back to now
super interesting thing
well in ministry for the future without
planning it what i think i did by
accident was to
take future history where history really
has happened and i jammed it into the
near future science fiction moment so
stuff that i used to write about
happening 200 years from now i said look
it's happening in the year 2035 or it's
starting right now